the radio show and outside the la talk
radio studios with mr. mark Rosen Bush
your site is internet marketing for
filmmakers calm curious about Blair
Witch Project and paranormal activity
could those two marketing campaigns you
do look yeah yeah I mean I think there's
yeah you have to take into account that
there's always sort of a zeitgeist of
what's going on in the world and timing
is always going to be a big factor and
you also have to understand that
certainly the time that Blair Witch
happened it was a very organic process
now there are a lot of tools that didn't
exist back then for doing large-scale
viral internet marketing paranormal
activity for example use this demanded
service which allowed people as they
became familiar with the movie just
seeing clips of it online and hearing
about it online to do this demanded
function
we asked for it to be shown in their
City and that created a sort of viral
thing so they're all sorts of tools like
that now certainly Facebook and Twitter
and other more traditional social media
tools can be used that way as well the
big piece of the puzzle is you need to
find something that's going to capture
the imagination in a viral way you can't
just you can't it's not just guesswork
and I know a lot of what I get
frustrated with is filmmaker they go
well i put it up on facebook and it's on
youtube why isn't it going viral there
are techniques that you can use to make
something move on for example there's
something that I teach a lot of call the
lower third which is when you put a
video on youtube or anywhere else you
take the lower third of that video and
you put your web address on it so that
all the time that they're watching that
video they're looking at your web
address which makes it much more likely
at the end of the video if they're
really interested in it to send it to
somebody also on the website you would
probably want to have if you want
something to go viral you want to have
multiple invitations to anybody who's
looking at a video or looking at a clip
or looking at a photo or whatever it is
that is the viral agent you want to
don't just hope that it's going to go
viral invite people to send it to their
friends and you know they're there
step-by-step formulas from making stuff
viral now for example of us was in the
film but just as a goof
in 2008 when Sarah Palin God's nominated
my friend Bob and I we were big Monty
Python geeks we had only ever heard of
Michael Palin so we came up with the
idea of creating Michael Palin for
president calm and we created a fake
political ad that was essentially saying
that Michael Palin as a member of Monty
Python and somebody who had traveled the
world doing documentaries and meeting
heads of state who in sitting history of
Cambridge University was more qualified
to run the free world than Sarah Palin
and we used Monty Python Eclipse to
demonstrate his qualifications we set up
this website and in doing literally we
slept together in five days we we we
came up with the idea we bought the
domain name we put the video together we
put up the website and then we send an
email to about 2,000 people so that the
email went out on the day that she was
speaking that Sarah Palin was speaking
at the Republican convention and they
got seen by 700,000 people within about
three to four weeks that was partly it
was lightning in a bottle because that
was the hot topic at that moment and it
was just a very funny idea at the right
time but it worked better than would
have otherwise because we did at the
lower third we did continually on any
page you were on on that website we were
the biggest thing on that page was tell
your friend send to a friend and we
actually know as a side effect we didn't
totally as a goof we were trying to make
a business out of it we also had an
opt-in box
collecting 12,000 email addresses and
Monty Python fans that love what we were
doing and they started sending us e-mail
saying can you sell us stuff and we
ended up making like eight ten thousand
dollars selling bumper stickers and then
through an amazon affiliate program body
pic on block sets and things the point
is that the viral thing can be
engineered the trick is you have to come
up with the right idea at the right time
and you have to have the mechanisms in
place you have to understand how the
mechanisms work and you have to invite
the people to do it now as far as
leverage or paranormal activity goes
before i get to paranormal activity
let's talk to a man about snakes on
plane viral in and of itself does not
guarantee success everybody thought the
website for snakes on a plane was great
but nobody went to see the movie and the
word of mouth on a movie from the people
that's miss very very bad viral is pure
word of mouth so the trick is you know
you can't guarantee like that that viral
is going to solve all your problems if
your movie is no good or if your
marketing isn't done in the right way
for all of the viral activity around
paranormal activity to me the thing that
paramount did which was genius which
wasn't viral at all was the trailer for
paranormal paranormal activity in fact
for my monthly members only site i did a
whole analysis of the trailer only sort
of the quick and dirty version up here
paranormal activity had so few shots in
it that would make up a good trailer
that they didn't sell the movie in the
trailer what they did was they sold the
perceived emotional experience that the
audience would have watching that movie
so the first shot of the trailer is a
bunch of people standing in line outside
the theater the second shot is a bunch
of people coming into the theater to
sitting down you then see the paramount
logo put your caramel logo doesn't even
fill the screen the paramount logo is
seen in the theater over the heads of
the audience so that psychologically and
emotionally you feel like you're in the
audience of that moment and then you see
little tiny clips from the movie barely
a couple of seconds each we're not even
that nothing that interesting even
happens but they would show a little
clip and then they cut straight back to
the audience and you watch the audience
reaction so the audience reaction was
the product that they were selling to
them exhaustive death and you know this
is one of the most brilliant trainers
I've ever seen because it was digging
deeply into the psychology and emotions
of the audience watching because there
was nothing there for within the Ewings
owns it's not whether the request of
whether the movies entered any good or
not but just there wasn't enough imagery
to pull out and make a traditional
trailer that was going to work and what
they ended up doing is creating the
illusion of a phenomenon even before it
wasn't enough and that was absolute
genius you know the vital part did
happen to some degree but i think you
know we know if you work for Paramount's
marketing department dont matta me but i
think a lot of the viral there was a lot
of shape about it being viral but again
you had Paramount's marketing budget
behind it Blair Lynch was pure viral
because the viral thing happened before
artisan bought
Sundance people were already talking
about it everywhere and for me that's a
much more important piece that I've been
trying to teach millimeters lately is
how do you build audience excitement
before the movie comes out how do you
build you know without having 40 million
dollar marketing budget or even 1
million dollar marketing budget you know
how do you use the viral tools on the
internet and social networking and blogs
and videos and all of that kind of stuff
to build a relationship with your
audience to pursue foremost and second
to create an emotional excitement around
the film and there are amazing
techniques for doing this that I've
learned outside of the film industry
that get used by grassroots internet
marketers for all sorts of products but
nobody except me seems to be teaching
this stuff to filmmakers within the film
industry and I think there's a huge
opportunity that we're going to see in
the next couple of years of film
starting to take advantage of some of
these techniques that are out there
because they work very simple they're
very powerful I'm not going to say that
it doesn't take some effort to put them
together and make them work properly but
they are doable in there